how many alien civilizations do you
think
are out there i don't have intuition for
that
um which i i have always thought was
deeply intriguing so
and and part of this uh i mean i say it
specifically is i don't have intuition
for that because it's like one of those
questions that you feel around for a
while and you really just
you you you can't see it um even though
it might be right there and um
in that sense it's a little like the
quantum to classical transition you're
like really talking about two different
kinds of physics and i
think that's kind of part of the problem
once we understand the physics that
question might become more meaningful
um but there's also this other issue um
uh and this was really instilled in me
by my mentor paul davies when i was a
postdoc because he
always talks about how you know whether
aliens are common or rare is kind of
just
um you know it's like you know it
follows a wave of popularity and it just
depends on like the mood of
you know what the culture is at the time
and i always thought that was kind of an
intriguing observation but
but also there's this you know set of
points about if you go by
observational evidence which we're
supposed to do with scientists right um
uh you know we have evidence of
us and one original life event from
which we emerged
and people want to make arguments that
because that event was rapid
or because there's other planets that
have property similar to ours that that
event should be common
but you actually can't reason on that
because our existence observing that
event is contingent on that
event happening which means it could
have been completely improbable or
very common and brandon carter like
clearly articulated that in terms of
anthropic arguments
a few decades ago so so there is this
kind of issue
that we have to contend with dealing
with life that's closer to home
than we have to deal with with any other
problems in physics which
we're talking about the physics of
ourselves and when you ask about the
original life event
that event happening in the universe at
least it's like our existence is
contingent on it
um and so you can think about sort of
fine-tuning arguments um
that way too so um but the the the sort
of odder part of it is like when i think
about
uh how likely it is i think it's because
we don't understand this mechanism yet
about how information can be generated
spontaneously
that i like because i can't see that
physics clearly yet even though i have a
lot of
you know like some things around the
space of it in my mind
i can't articulate how likely that
process is
um so my honest answer is i don't know
and it sometimes
feels like a cop-out but i feel like
that's a more honest answer and a more
meaningful way of making progress
than um what a lot of people want to do
which is say oh well we have a one in
ten chance of having on an exoplanet
with earth-like properties because
there's lots of earth-like planets out
there and life happened fast on earth
well so i have kind of a follow-up
question but as a side comment
what i really am enjoying about the way
you're talking about human beings is you
always say not to make yourself
conscious about it because i really
really enjoy it
do you say we yes you don't say humans
you say because often times like and you
know i don't know evolutionary
biologists will kind of
put yourself out yes as an observer but
you're
it's it's kind of fascinating to think
that you as a human are struggling about
your own origins
yes that's the problem and yeah and i
i think um i don't do that deliberately
but i do think that way and this is sort
of the inversion from the logic of
physics because physics as it's always
been constructed
has treated us as external observers of
the universe and we are not part of the
universe and this is why
the problem of life i think demands
completely new thinking because we have
to think about ourselves
as minds that exist in the universe and
are at this particular moment in history
and looking out at the things around us
and trying to understand what we are
inside the system not outside the system
we don't have
descriptions at a fundamental level that
describe us as inside the system
and this was my problem with cellular
automata also you're always an external
observer
for a cellular automata you're not in
the system what does the cellular
automata look like from the inside
i think you just broke my brain with
that question exactly but i thought
about that for a long time but
i'm gonna uh yeah that's a that's a
really clean formulation of a very
fundamental question
because you can only to understand
cellular autonomy you have to be inside
of it
but as a human sort of a poetic romantic
question
does it make you sad does it make you
hopeful
whether we're alone or not like in the
different possible versions of that
if we're the highest assembly object in
the entire
universe does that at this moment in
time
at this moment in the causality because
we might assume we have a future
well we definitely have a future and the
question is what yeah
where that future decreases the assembly
like
it could be where at the peak or we
could be just
um that would be inconsistent with the
physics in my mind
but so so i i should give a caveat i've
given the the caveat that i'm biased as
a physicist but i'm also biased as an
eternal optimist so pretty much
all of my modes of operation for
building theories about the world
are not like an occam's razor what's the
simplest explanation but what's the most
optimistic explanation
and part of the reason for that is if
you really think explanations have
causal power
um in the sense that our theo like the
fact that we have theories about the
world has enabled technologies and
physically transformed the world around
us i think i have to take seriously that
as a part of the physics i want to
describe
and try to build
theories of reality that are optimistic
about what's coming next because the
theories are in part the causes of what
comes next
so there could be a physics of hope or
physics of optimism in there too yes
because um that seems like also i mean
optimism
does seem to be a kind of engine that
results in innovation
yes so this is dr like what why the hell
are we trying to come up with new stuff
oh so
um so i made this point about thinking
life is the physics of existence and
it's not just the physics of existence
it's the physics
of more things existing so i think one
of these drives
yeah creativity like optimism the story
so
if you like is people like entropy i
don't i don't like entropy as it was
formulated in the 1800s i think it's an
antiquated concept
but um but this idea of maximizing
over the possible number of states that
could exist imagine the universe is
actually trying to maximize over the
number of things that could physically
exist
what would be the best way to do that
the best way to do that would be evolve
intelligent technological things that
could explore that space
you